so how our council decide what to do in
a district we want to hear what you
think the question is simple give you
support shops opening the trading on
Easter Sunday do you think that
businesses should be given the option to
open on easter sunday if they want to so
it's optional really yes optional they
should be closed yes yes the police
raided boy pick up with an eye open
intelligence some people find your
family days on me today but for little
shops I mean they kind of need the
business so I would have been through
having me Martin per se because I'm
RELIGIOUS I won't ever open I don't see
the informal from Dino I haven't written
a piece okay I don't see Blake out I
mean you know everyone's got the day off
and I want to have a look around and it
was family of stuff I should be able to
go on the shelf never look around
they're doing we have heard what they
have to say what do you think clips talk
you can make your feedback nine on our
website Facebook or at any of our
service center if the trading is just
one topic covered in our draft and your
plan visit Waimakariri govt kings or
incest to find out more and have your
say
I
you
[Music]